at trudeau airport in montreal some
travelers say they're ready to pile onto
packed planes again regardless of their
neighbor's vaccination status it's about
time i think personally others worry not
necessarily for themselves but for those
traveling without increased protection i
think we're fine i think the
unvaccinated people are the guys you
have to worry
on this via rail platform some
trepidation
i think it's premature yes proof of
vaccination for air and rail travel has
been mandatory since october
but as montreal revs up for one of the
biggest events on the summer calendar
the formula one canadian grand prix the
news of relaxed domestic travel
requirements represent a bit of relief
for the beleaguered tourism industry
another step in the right direction
that's for sure
the industry isn't altogether happy it
still wants inbound international
travelers to be exempt from vaccine
rules over 50 countries have moved
forward in terms of
international
allowing international travel so i think
we'd like to see canada do the same
cruises still require anyone on a ship
get a covet shot too they were closed
down for two solid years we didn't have
cruise ships coming into port and it's a
real challenge
for them the hope is that unvaccinated
public sector employees being allowed
back to work could help relieve staff
shortages contributing to long lines at
airports even still canadians are being
asked to pack their patients as more
people traveling might further expose
worker shortages in hotels restaurants
and other attractions a recommendation
is travelers you know should be patient
and and should be nice to the people who
are serving them the tourism industry
hopes the mandate suspension is made
permanent so businesses and travelers
can confidently plan for the future and
replace unknowns with certainties dan
specter global news montreal